most people have a stressful life and if
you look at stress stress happens as a
result of things not fitting your
pictures perfection is the lowest
standard and the reason it's the lowest
standard is because it's unattainable
failure failure is not taking the step
failure is not picking up the baton
swinging it at life failure is getting
to the end of this game I'm regretting
what we didn't do
I'm a born entrepreneur I built several
dozen companies half of which before the
age of 30 are the best-selling author
philosopher and Explorer of
consciousness my name is Peter sage and
these are my 10 rules for success
[Music]
probably the most important way to
encourage yourself to work harder is to
increase your Y if it is psychological
fact that people do things for reasons
now there may not be your reasons when
the may not be my reasons but everybody
does things for reasons and so what you
do when you're working harder or you're
working on a project you're doing it
because there's a reason for it now if
your motivation is low it's because your
reason the reason that you're doing it
doesn't resonate at a high level so how
do you increase your Y well one of the
ways I found is to by focusing on what
is the outcome of what it is that you're
doing and how can I serve beyond you to
people that you care about or the world
at large people can be motivated by
themselves up to a point
but when you start motivating yourself
because of what you can contribute you
tap into a deeper level of motivation
you know it's a fact if you look at the
the New York Marathon the Boston
Marathon the London Marathon there's
more people that run those marathons for
the first time running for other people
causes charities and think about how
much it would take to motivate yourself
if you've never ran a marathon before to
go and train for one you know in getting
up when you need to do a 20k or a 15
mile training run and it's cold and wet
and miserable you haven't eaten properly
and you're tired but you got to go do it
anyway if we're doing it for ourselves a
lot of the time we can quit but if
you're doing it to others with something
that compels us you know if you've got
to get up early to go get yourself to a
certain place and you're not feeling
motivated it's hard but if you've got to
get up and go because your boss will
fire you if you don't we've got to pick
the kids up from the airport yeah
there's a different reason so focus on
what it is that is your why and check-in
is it self-serving which is limiting in
its power or is it more ethnocentric
whereby I'm doing it for a reason and
find a reason to be able to contribute
with what it is what you're doing over
time and especially impulse development
many people have put different emphasis
on different buzzwords things like
persistence and desire and determination
words they usually have a lot of
strength behind them words that really
have a con
a Shinto you know being able to battle
through and while things like desire
persistence determination etc are very
useful they're useful for when we go
through obstacles when we require an
immediate injection of force to try and
break through certain levels of
limitation in other words if we are
sitting there as a victim of life and we
want to be able to break out and take
charge of our own circumstances words
like persistence and desire and being
able to break through our valuable words
but I'd like to give you an insight into
a word that I think is far more powerful
and this word has been given to us
throughout the ages by prophets scholars
religious teachers spiritual masters
consistently since the dawn of written
civilization and that is the word
surrender the word surrender is inherent
into letting go of resistance if you
think of for example stress most people
have a stressful life and if you look at
stress stress happens as a result of
things not fitting your pictures in
other words if you take the scientific
definition it's two objects going
against each other with opposing forces
in opposite directions not like for
example if you take a dam tonight I'm
doing a South advance and I take a lady
on an outside turn then we're going in
opposite directions
and that's fine you're going with the
flow but if she's trying to move on an
inside turn and I'm doing an outside
turn you have a friction a resistance
and that's going to end up in a broken
wrist so you know being able to
surrender at that point has a different
connotation so let's look into it a
little more if we're trying to force our
way through life battling through
surrender is not an option for most
people but if we start to look deeper
and know that the wisdom behind the
intelligence that governs a lot of the
flow of the river of life let's call it
the current of life has an innate level
of intelligence that goes beyond what we
can comprehend consciously how do I know
that very simple cut your finger and
consciously try to stop it from healing
yeah there's something smarter than
assets at work there whereas you know if
we were to surrender to the wisdom of
the current of the river if we were to
surrender to that level of in
intelligence then what generally happens
is that a solution to our problems will
present itself if you want to flow with
the wisdom of the current know that if
life takes a left turn which it has to
you know you look at any river from the
air and regardless of the topography
regardless of where you are on a planet
they all follow the same pattern they
wind just like the roads around me in
the background here they all wind in a
different pattern so if you have a goal
in mind and you're you know you have
gone through persistence you've gone
through determination and it's still
struggling try surrendering to the
inevitability of it happening by flowing
with the wisdom of the current and if
you do that you tap into that innate
level of wisdom that has been passed
down through the ages you'll start to
see surrender as alignment with the
current rather than resisting it if we
understand that for the majority of
people on the planet money is nothing
more than a reflection of the value that
they've added then we start to
understand that you know what has to
come first
is the value not going around chasing
money if you chase money you'll chase
your tail because you're chasing the
consequence of something that hasn't
happened yet that makes sense so if you
look at it under that context then how
do you start a business with no money
well you don't ask yourself where do I
get money you ask yourself a better
question you say where is it that I can
add value how can I add value what is it
that I can contribute that would cause
somebody to be able to give me what it
is that I want without just shelling out
a wad of cash yeah that's the easy way
that's you know all money is as an
arbitrary medium of exchange to measure
different levels of value that's pretty
much it so if we don't have access to
money then what we have to do is come up
with ways we can add value and therefore
we shortcut the process one of the
patterns that I'm noticing here Eric in
in a lot of consistent ways with new
entrepreneurs is that they're covering
up their lack of ability to handle
uncertainty by doing research under the
guise of chasing perfectionism yeah
alright that's like so listen I'm going
to read all the books on darts that I
can read so that my first dart is going
to be a bull's eye
yeah that doesn't work get up stand up
to the plate out of iake throw the dart
and the first one may miss the board but
then you adjust you throw the second one
it gets a little closer you throw the
third one it gets a little closer now
eventually you're going to be getting
bull's-eyes because you're used to
throwing not used to reading books on
darts you express it's better than
getting better than this one I'll see if
I'm trying to be perfect then - all you
perfectionist people out there listen to
me again another one of my mentor I
spent on many years with Tony Robbins
right well telly perfection is the
lowest standard and the reason it's the
lowest standard is because it's
unattainable so what you're trying to be
perfect by being perfect you guarantee
you never will be even most people try
to view photos you want so deluded most
people are afraid of being imperfect I
think that it is written go to the roof
estimation buildin it will get nasal
under the guise of researchers yeah all
are just gonna do two more focus groups
all just like you know as do another
hours surfing to see if there's any
other ideas I can benchmark no shut up
do your research area limit it getting
the game swing the bat then reassess but
at least you in the game set yourself up
to win now this may sound easy but let
me give you some insight into brain
chemistry now one of my my good friends
Dave Asprey from the bulletproof team
yeah amazing man shared this with me and
that is that the brain although its
150th of the body weight takes up 20% of
the calories 2070 energy in your body
goes to run your brain now if that
energy is low guess what you feel
demotivated and a lot of the time people
try and rely on willpower but willpower
isn't on demand willpower has cycles
based upon whether your brain is being
fed the energy it needs so if you are
feeling down and thinking I just I was
going to commit that but I can't I just
not in the mood and you don't to work
harder then first things first
go check your brain chemistry go and get
yourself some fast yeah the sugars into
the diet
some high-quality brain fuel to be able
to perk yourself back up at that level
then go do it another great way of
setting yourself up to win is that when
you're in the mood to do something
prepare something for when you're going
to be doing the project in other words
I'll give you an example if you go to
bed at night put your gym kit at the
bottom of the bed if you're going to the
gym in the morning research is shown if
you get out of bed and that gym kit is
more than twenty seconds away you're not
likely to make it if you're not in the
mood but if your gym kit is at the foot
of the bed and you get out the first
thing you do is put it on your head of
the game set yourself up to win yeah so
when I'm in the mood night I'm energized
my brain chemistry's high and I'm
associated to it to what I'm doing do
something in that moment to take action
towards setting yourself up when you
know predictably that cycle is going to
get because you can't be an uptime all
the while that's a superhuman myth well
here's the tip it's not looking for more
sales it's not getting up earlier and
making calls it's not knocking on doors
the fastest way to make money is to
raise yourself work how do you raise
yourself worth check your peer group if
you upgrade your peer group you will
upgrade yourself work case closed what I
mean by that well if you hang around
with ten drug addicts I've got news for
you the law of Conformity says you'll
likely become the 11th if you hang
around with ten highly motivated
self-made multi-millionaire that are up
and busier but on purpose with something
and inspired to go out and create value
you'll likely become the 11th if they
raise your self-esteem trade your peer
group and ask yourself the question how
can I add value and all of a sudden you
look over your shoulder won anything Wow
where did that money come from because
now you're focusing on what you can give
which is the byproducts or a consequence
of that is money coming in rather than
sitting in front of the fire and
bitching about the fact that it's cold
and if only you had some heat you'll go
outside and play some wood that doesn't
work you want more money become a person
of value upgrade your self-worth mix
with the people that already have what
it is that you want contribute and
adding value and I guarantee money won't
be far behind
if you are able to
and that you get to choose the meaning
of what happens you get to take
responsibility for your data processing
of the five senses in our two men sat
behind prison bars once all mud the
other source stars the condition is
identical in both scenarios how one
chooses to interpret that condition
determines whether or not you go off on
a track towards empowerment or whether
you go off on a track that becomes a
self-fulfilling prophecy of more stress
and resentment with your current life
condition if you've ever had a
relationship with somebody or an
intimate relationship where for example
they left you at same scenario two
different ways of looking at it one you
can't answer we'll unclearly no good so
they left me or you can say well thank
God they weren't so they made room for
somebody who is right next now just stay
with that example for a second you
suddenly go out and yeah a year later
six months down the line whatever it is
if I'm on the first scenario I'm no good
so they left me and that's my belief
that's all it is has nothing to do with
the actual event the event is the event
but if I'm processing my data management
through the filter or the belief or the
choice of I'm no good so they left me
because that's my story that's you know
my upbringing that's my social
conditioning that's my parents that's my
fill-in-the-blank yeah we all have a
story my friends then the next time I go
to meet somebody or I'm introduced to
somebody what are my default thoughts uh
I wonder if this person thinks I'm good
enough now if that's your starting place
I can predict what's going to happen
over the next two dates if you get to
date number two that is whereas if you
turn around at the you know if we rewind
six months before and you say next oh
yeah thank goodness that person went so
they made room for somebody who's right
and that is your default level of
processing because it's a choice then
next time you meet somebody what is your
default level of being able to interact
as well yeah I wonder if this person is
going to be fortunate enough to spend
some time with me as long as it comes
from a place of authenticity not
arrogance yeah because you're feeling
empowered not disempowered yeah your
second dates going to be a very
different experience
you understand what I'm saying we create
our interpretation of meaning of the
world irrespective of the external
circumstances if I'm going to do
business with somebody I want to do
business with somebody I like and
somebody I trust now we all want to be
in business with those people so you
know what does it take to like somebody
and trust somebody if you're putting on
some level of fake rapport skills
because you've learned some NLP
technique on how to be closely in
alignment with somebody who's visual
versus auditory or kinesthetic then
that's going to get you in the door but
there's an inherent level of false misen
Sara T comes from a level of empathy and
intention that is is there to express
who you are to serve your client if you
don't have the ability to respect your
time nobody else will yeah now it
doesn't mean it let me to say you've got
to be a jerk about it now there is
something respectful about people who
own their own time and if somebody calls
me and says or young or calls goes
through my secretary said they want a
meeting nobody gets access to to time
with me unless they send an agenda in
advance and you know we assess it as
being mutually beneficial yeah otherwise
yeah I'm not going to be able to focus
on what my mission is I'm going to be
serving everybody else's now you see
many people avoid that because they have
a fear of rejection they don't like
saying no I don't want to hurt
somebody's feeling yeah this will remain
problem like you know you can just give
it them to someone that's not about them
that's about you yeah being driven by
the good opinion of others and ask a
love rejection because you think yeah
it's it's a personal shock or if you own
yourself and you own your truth it's
very easy to say no the people's right
now I've employed hundreds of people
over the years in different businesses
and sometimes you've got to let go of
people and I don't see that as ruining
their day I see that as giving them an
opportunity to be in a job that's better
suited to them now they may not see that
at the time limit load Emily Assateague
employment there or the fact that
they're yeah they don't have wages next
week yeah but you know I don't want them
being in a place where they don't fit
and if they don't have the courage to
recognize that and leave it then I'm the
guy that needs to help and three months
down the line one they hopefully get a
better job
yeah or find themselves in a better
position than they look back at the time
when the transition point was there they
thanked me for having the courage to
make that decision for them if they
didn't so I don't need the good opinion
of others if I'm walking my truth and
I'm always coming from a place of
wanting to serve it's not an
ethnocentric so it's not an egocentric
position I'm not trying to say well
screw you your times my time is more
important than yours I'm saying well
right now this doesn't serve our outcome
it's got to be a level of mutual benefit
yeah it's being really beneficial and if
you need some time and this is a project
you want my advice on then a I have an
hourly rate that you can book but if
you're looking for free advice I have a
huge amount of information out there on
YouTube that I do so that people that
can't afford my time yeah can have
access to some benefit but other than
that I'm very sorry my time on my
mission isn't aligned with where yours
is right now now if there's one area
that I see stopping so many people from
living their dream from fulfilling the
potential that they were born to fulfill
it is getting over the fear of failure
so how do you do that how do you take
that fear and rip it out by the roots
and throw it away so it never bothers
you again you start to understand what
fear of failure actually is because for
many people all it is is being
sucker-punched by the good opinion of
other people caring about what they
think you know how often that keeps us
down you know how much of a life is
wasted caring about what we think other
people are thinking I mean yeah and the
reality is this you start as the the
number one a list actor in your movie
called your life do you not which means
that everybody else is either a
supporting cast or a film extra in the
movie of your life correct but what does
that really mean we walk around thinking
people look at us as the star in our
movie but they don't everybody else is
living the same dream though
looking around and start their own movie
and we're just a filmmaker in their
movie so if we stop taking the actions
that we think will lead towards success
because we think we're worried about
what the good opinion of other people
will do to us I got news for you so
listen carefully I don't get on my
soapbox about many things but I'm
getting on it about this guy yeah
nobody cares enough about you to bother
to give an opinion because they're too
busy being worried about what they think
you're thinking of them alias failure is
not taking the step failure is not
picking up the baton swinging it at life
failure is getting to the end of this
game I'm regretting what we didn't do
failure is about saying whatever failure
is lying on your deathbed thinking oh
well if only I could go back and do fill
in the blank you know something to me
fairly isn't falling down it's staying
down when you fall it you have to fail
by the definition of all I didn't
succeed in order so you can succeed
that's what life is about it's not about
taking it with you at the end it's not
about scorekeeping I probably failed
more times than I've won but I keep my
average number of tries high and you
know what happens guess what you tap
into the lesson of history that most
people ignore and that is this is a
paradox of history but those that risk
the least in life usually end up with
the least in life just because that
brain won't tell us that well we have to
pay a mortgage on Friday doesn't mean it
isn't true so get up and get in the game
who you are right now watching this is
as a result of your failure is not your
successes it is when we're testing when
the storm is ripping the branches of a
tree you know when the rain clouds are
there we think we've got nothing left
that's who we are at our best when we
show up when we tested the strongest
trees grow in the strongest winds not in
the best oil so next time you have an
opportunity next time you start a
question whether you should step forward
or not or will it be a white square on
the chessboard
who cares get in the game swing the bat
being all you can be
get up and if anybody says oh you're
doing that or or you did that all look
at you failed no this they're failing in
their judgment of you not in your
ability to pick up the baton swing it
again that's the person you were born to
be my friends right that's the person
who you are you were born a miracle you
are good enough you don't need me to
tell you that you already are
get out there get in the game go embrace
it and if you fall over pick yourself up
swing the bat again and let's go play
this game of life
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Kevin Lai asked
me to if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you are me the profiles next leave
in the comments below I will see what I
can do I'd also love to know what did
Peter say that has the biggest impact on
you in your business your life what
change you're going to make after
watching this video please leave in the
comments and I'm going to join in the
discussion finally want to give a quick
shout-out to jaslyne purification thank
you so much for picking up a cup of my
book and making that awesome face book
art that you posted I really really
really appreciate it so thank you guys
again for watching I believe in you I
hope to continue to believe in yourself
and whatever your one where it is let's
love I'll see you soon
determination for me is far more
important than desire desire comes from
a place of thinking I need it therefore
the presupposition is I'm not good
enough because I don't already have it
determination is simply a case of role
there's one focuses where I'm going yeah
I don't need it I'm just choosing to get
it and get out of the damn way because
I'm moving questions direct our focus
and if you're not directing your own
focus I've got news for you there's a
lot of people that pay a lot of good
money to Madison Avenue is a figure and
a spirit for you and yeah and that's and
that's not the life you want to live
being programmed by other people's
agendas and you know I liken the mind to
a compass needle you can only point in
one direction at a time and the
challenge is just like if we take a
needle of magnetize it like back in high
school
now you take a magnet a power source and
you align it and keep stroking that
needle in one continuous direction for
that needle aligns to the magnetic field
and becomes coherent pointed that all of
the ions point in one direction it
becomes magnetized now our mind is very
similar now if we are open to
unconsciously being programmed which
unfortunately as human beings we are you
know we wear a 24/7 constant adaptation
machine now our mind and our body now we
understand the body part that's easy now
the physical side of life everybody gets
because they have experience all their
evidence call now your body will adapt
if you put in McDonald's or if you put
it in the gym if it doesn't mind it will
adapt accordingly yeah that's its job
but our mind is far more programmable
far quicker than our body and if the
magnet is the strong force is constantly
magnetizing us is usually the media and
our peer group and if those two are
optimal then we're going to be sucked
along for the ride and don't really
magnetize our true north for ourselves
so by asking better questions well it
does it shift the direction of that
needle now the challenge is you can only
do that some percent of the time that
you're conscious or sleeping
because how most people are 90% of the
time that's why when we're driving to
work we can't remember the last two
kilometers on the freeway here not what
happened
but now if we focus on being able to
magnetize or take charge of which
direction a compass needle is pointing
we should have a chance to start reading
mailing ourselves because otherwise yeah
again you're going to be drifting
especially at 90 percent at the time
when we do things out of habit
unconsciously that compass needle drifts
back to it precondition magnetic north
and most the time that doesn't serve us
and whether its media condition peer
group conditions and gear Society
condition look out of your window
there's not many example to who we
really want to emulate and become this
around us on a day to day basis there is
a way believe it or not you can actually
be luckier and it's much simpler then
you realize especially when you
understand some of the science and the
biochemistry and neuro chemistry as to
what's really going on and you know what
I say lucky I'm talking about things
kids falling into place feeling in so or
you know if you meet the right person or
what deal runs on your plate and a lot
of this is actually able to see you're
able to set this up in a way where the
odds are more in your favor
just like if you're in a casino life for
some people is where you put enough
quarters in the machine and you know you
may get three cherries in a row because
there's so much going on in life so many
plates spinning simultaneously but
occasionally yes you'll just be lucky
and getting three cherries in a row that
happens but what often they're not how
do we stack the odds in our favor
now if you go to the roulette table and
you're betting black and red the house
will always win over time why because
it's not 5050 and is also a little green
option called zero which stacked the
odds in the houses favor yeah a little
bit more than 50% so mathematically the
house will always win you may get lucky
but the house always went over time so
how do you go from being a person
spinning the wheel in life hoping that
it's going to land on your collar this
is becoming the house where by every
single time over time you know
ultimately things are going to work out
in your favor well let me share with you
an incredible part of the human anatomy
that allows that to happen
it's called the reticular activating
system and it's a part of the brain that
has a very specific job to do and it's
usually misunderstood so there were six
activating system is really the
gravekeeper between the conscious and
the unconscious mind and it has way over
what information it allows them from the
sensory input now how do we make the
reticular activating system work for us
when we want to be quote unquote lucky
well we need to understand that it does
one job and one job only primarily for
the purposes of this video and that is
it allows in to our conscious
information that falls under two
categories one is information that can
be harmful to us and the other is
information that we vote on it being
relevant so for example let's talk about
the first ya type of information stuff
that can be harmful so we're driving
along and with somewhat unconscious as
most people I want to call sleeping
awake which is why you tend to drive to
work on your day off because you've done
it so many times you're unconscious
you're moving forward just how to have
it but we tend to have a wake up just as
the car in front of us breaks out little
early snaps us out that's because the
reticular activating system is
constantly scanning for something that
could be danger and it works in
conjunction with another part of the
brain called the amygdala whose job is
to really notice things that are
negative or dangerous before
positive so the amygdala will notice
that flag it up to the Richard Kerr
activating system bring it into your
conscious awareness while everything
else meanwhile is swept under the carpet
so in the amygdala the fascinating part
of the brain as I say if you're walking
past the tree ten thousand years ago and
you miss an apple no big deal
but if you miss a snake it could be a
big deal so it's always scanning in
conjunction with the reticular
activating system to see if there's
anything in our winds that could be
dangerous harmful or threaten loss
physical so in terms of the other
information what we tell it is important
now here's where we start getting
interesting when we talk about getting
lucky see the reticular activating
system will as a faithful servant
irrespective of the nature of the input
do its job so if you for example am name
we know our name is important to us so
with we're at a party and we're having a
conversation with somebody and there's
lots of background conversations going
on with somebody the other side of the
room alkanes can mention a name in mid
conversation we will be pulled out and
look over to see who mentioned our name
across the room in the middle of a lot
of conversation why is that because the
reticular activating system is
constantly scanning all of this
information and it's deleting distorting
and generalizing 99% of it I say
otherwise would be completely
overwhelmed and it's sweeping that under
the carpet of our awareness our
conscious awareness and just fighting
out what's important that's why we
didn't have somebody else's name but we
would hear our name so if we tell the
reticular activating system what is
important it will go and find it in the
millions of bytes and bits of
information a second that is being
processed so you could walk down the
street and completely miss an
opportunity because you haven't told the
reticular activating system where your
brain that it is relevant or important
even though it's walking up millions of
pieces of information every second
example if you have a six-year-old
daughter and she turns how to say daddy
daddy please I would love a bike for my
birthday please that's all I want is a
bike not ok honey and you say to your
wife here I've got to get any other
daughter a bike and you're driving to
work the next day
and all of them you drive past a bike
shop and you notice a bike shop on the
way to work now it's been there for the
last five years every day you've driven
to work
you noticed it in your reticular
activating system but because you
haven't told your branding is important
it swept it under the carpet of
awareness and you didn't notice it in
your conscious but now you said it's
relevant so it pulls it out of all of
the information says hey guess what Wow
just the same as if you buy a car and
you stop seeing that car everywhere on
the road of course it was there before
and there wasn't a half-price sale on
and everybody's bought the same car no
you've now told your reticular
activating system this particular car
make model color what have you is now
more relevant to me in my life and then
out of the hundreds of thousands of cars
on the road whenever it spots one is it
always did it will flag it up now basic
neuroscience so how do we make that work
for us well if it's going to constantly
24/7 look for all the information that
is out there that's beyond our conscious
comprehension our ability to process
consciously and start scanning what a
great opportunity thanks so if I turn
around and say and right now I'm looking
for a business partner I'm looking for a
store in two premises a vacant premises
I'm looking for certain kind of property
new sets relevant you can start noticing
things like that while you're driving
along in the process of normal
conversations when you're standing in
the lineup at Starbucks overhearing
somebody talk about a business that's
relevant to you because you're telling
it it's important